meet Priscilla Valentine the leader of
Valentine's performing pigs everyone
should take a new look at pigs they are
not just pork chops vasila and her
husband Steve raise train and perform
Vietnamese pot-bellied pigs they are
preparing for a show at the American Pet
Expo in California one of the largest
pet shows in America
training pigs means working with their
natural behaviors she's always thinking
you can just see it in her eyes just
like their wild cousins these pigs know
executing certain behaviors can yield
tasty results a star of the show is a
pig named Nellie she's the brains of the
operation using her smarts for an
ingenious take on bowling Nellie was
simply supposed to knock the bowling
balls down and one time she danced and
she used her snout to knock the balls
down because she figured it out
well the idea of the trick is to knock
the pins down so why does it have to be
a ball in Denver Colorado another pig
shows off his intelligence this is mud
slinging a ten month old pot-bellied pig
that's already learned 40 different
behaviors mud slingers learning to weave
between my legs at ten months old this
was absolutely amazing how fast he's
learned this trick John Vincent is an
aerospace engineer but he also leads a
performing troupe called the top hogs
what are you gonna do if I walk
backwards
oh yeah I'd love to be mentally
challenged they'd love to learn they
don't just go through the steps of a
behavior they actually think through it
they see the beginning in the end and
then they figure out how to get there I
realized how smart pigs really are when
one of the pigs was rolling a golf ball
to the hole and he was having trouble
getting it in the hole well he knew the
point of the trick was to get the ball
in the hole mudslinger actually pushes
the golf ball over and then lifts the
hole up and puts it over the golf ball
some scientists believe this
problem-solving ability means pigs are
capable of what's called lateral
learning the ability to see an objective
and imagine new ways to get there